finland's prime minister says her
country will make a decision on joining
nato within weeks sana marine is holding
talks with her swedish counterpart
magdalena anderson as their country's
way of joining the military alliance
sweden and finland are not members of
nato but marine and anderson say
europe's security landscape has changed
following russia's invasion of ukraine
they're now considering whether their
country's security would be improved
through nato membership but say the
decision needs careful consideration
both finland and sweden make
independently their decisions regarding
security policy arrangements
but we do that with a clear
understanding that our choices will
affect not only ourselves but our
neighbours as well
our aim is clear we want to guarantee
peace in the future for us and for our
region for europe and to contribute
towards that aim with our own choices
we have to analyze the situation to see
what is best for sweden's security for
the swedish people in this new situation
and you shouldn't rush into that you
should make it very seriously that is
how i work as the swedish prime minister
dw correspondent jack parrack is
following this story for us from
brussels which is home to nato
headquarters and we asked him to tell us
more about finland's decision-making
process
what we've heard now from sanamar
enjoying this press conference is that
they the parliament will now start their
discussions on this and whether that
would take a referendum in the country
or not it seems the finnish president
actually recently said that it might not
take a referendum and that perhaps the
parliament should should do it
themselves and that's because there's
they say overwhelming evidence that the
finns are now in favor of nato
membership
different polls put it somewhere between
sort of 65 to 75 percent of finns after
the invasion of ukraine are now now in
favor of of joining the nato military
alliance and both of the leaders of
sweden and finland talked about the need
or or the use of article 5 of nato's
agreements of the treaty which is one
for all defense so if one country in
nato is attacked then all of the other
countries come to their defense it seems
that they will start those negotiations
it's a delicate balance finland has a 1
300 kilometer plus border with russia
and rece just in in the recent weeks
dmitry peskov the kremlin spokesperson
though said that if the countries were
to join then russia would have to
rebalance the situation and whether that
would mean that russia would then put
troops up near that border with finland
that would obviously be a concern for
the people of finland as well
what about sweden jack
well from the swedish point of view i
think we can say from that press
conference they're slightly more
reluctant there's slightly more
hesitancy in stockholm they as well
though since the since the invasion of
ukraine have seen a jump to
over 60 percent of people wanting to to
join nato there's also the question
about whether that would be done by a
referendum sweden's eu commissioner
recently ilvio hansen said that she
didn't think that should be done that
actually referendums aren't necessarily
the right way to make these sort of
important national decisions and also
will remember a significant decision in
the european union when britain decided
to leave on a referendum through a slim
margin where such important decisions
perhaps shouldn't always be put to the
people is the sense amongst these things
but certainly now what we're seeing is
that the questions over nato membership
both of these countries hold what's
called an enhanced opportunity
partnership with nato they are involved
in some of the drills uh and and some of
their some of their work but now the the
discussions about whether they're going
to join are really getting to the finer
points
dw correspondent jack parrack weighing
in from brussels there